[Music]
it was an incredible sight more and more
people gathered in front of notre-dame
Cathedral which was burning before their
very eyes they sang and prayed together
Parisians and tourists from around the
world the fire had already been raging
for three hours
the iconic twin bell towers were in
danger of collapsing many here were
hoping for a miracle
like Josiane and le Christians from
Lebanon there's water on either side but
it's on fire and they can't put it out
even in France with all of its modern
technology they can't put it out we're
praying to God if men can't do it maybe
the good Lord will help us it's not just
not the dawn of France or Paris it's not
you Dom of all humanity even the Muslims
next to us started singing with us when
they saw we were singing in Arabic much
of note radars roof had collapsed the
fate of its invaluable artworks and
relics was still unclear for me this is
the symbol of Paris I'm in love with
Paris and its art and culture that this
could happen to such a powerful symbol I
can't believe it
people hoped and prayed firefighters
could put out the fire there'd never
been one like this at no TRADOC many of
the beams in the church's wooden frame
were almost a thousand years old
Notre Dame is my heart my soul I'm a
Parisian born in Paris to me it's our
most important building everyone cried
tonight I stood beside Muslims Jews
blacks whites this United everyone it
touches our soul and breaks our hearts
some people stayed all night then in the
early hours of the morning the fire
department announced that the blaze was
under control though the damage is huge
many of the most important artworks were
rescued veruno chef Mei who long worked
for the Roman Catholic Archdiocese of
Paris is relieved and impressed by how
many people of all religions stood
together city last night the grand rabbi
of France cited the Old Testament that's
common to both Christians and Jews the
prophet Isaiah said my house will be
called a house of prayer for all peoples
and that's what Notre Dame represents
for Christians of course but for all men
of good faith whether they be Jews
Muslims or otherwise even non-believers
some say it's a miracle no true DOM is
still standing I believe in resurrection
North Ladon will rise again due to the
extraordinary solidarity of those
mobilizing to rebuild it I think we're
capable of doing it it may be
differently but we have to do it no
matter what the cost
it'll be huge but that doesn't matter it
must be done no true Dom in Paris are
experiencing an outpouring of solidarity
people around the globe want to help
restore the treasured Cathedral to its
former glory